in september 2018 a mysterious louisiana
investor completed one of the biggest
land sales in recent memory
14 500 acres of farmland for almost 171
million dollars
the name of the area the 100 circles
to put the sail into perspective 14 500
acres is about the size of new york's
manhattan island
when you look at farmland sales you're
typically talking about hundreds of
acres
but thousands of acres those are blue
moon events made by very big buyers
like the 6 000 acre purchased in 2020
made by the ontario teachers pension
plan
but tens of thousands of acres
that's when you start getting into the
territory of sovereign wealth funds
and huge institutional investors and
that's exactly who the seller in this
transaction was
john hancock life insurance an insurance
company in boston with billions under
management
and the buyer it had to be someone as
big if not bigger than a billion dollar
insurance company
and that's what this reporter eric
o'keefe at the lamb report set out to
find
o'keefe found out about this giant sale
from an article the tri-city herald
published
and in that article the buyer was
described as a louisiana investor that
was a limited liability company
associated with the angelina agriculture
company
in moderate louisiana the only problem
o'keefe's the land report tracks many of
the louisiana land owners
and if there was one with deep enough
pockets for this type of deal they would
have known about them
and angelina agriculture was not one of
them strike number one
so o'keeffe dug deeper well monterey
louisiana where the buyer is located
is a bustling city with a population of
462.
not 462 4462.
how about we take a look at the company
itself digging through the documents
okey found that angelina agriculture the
company that just spent 171 million
dollars
has just two employees and makes a
little over three hundred thousand
dollars a year
at that rate angelina agriculture would
have had to save every penny they made
at a hundred percent profit margins
for over half a millennium to afford 171
million dollars of farmland
strike number two how about we take a
look at the headquarters of this company
8318 highway 565 moderate louisiana
o'keeffe pulled up google maps and would
you look at that the purchaser of the
biggest land grab in recent history
is a metal shed in the middle of nowhere
so in summary a 171 million dollar
acquisition was made by an llc which is
three hundred thousand dollars in
revenue
two employees in a metal shed in the
middle of nowhere
strike number three so o'keefe forwarded
his findings to his land report 100
research team
a few minutes later he gets this
response ever heard of bill gates bill
gates is a billionaire not because he
made an operating system
but because he went into a new industry
and today one of those new industries is
big data
data is the new oil those who have data
and know how to analyze it today
will rule tomorrow that's where today's
video sponsor comes in
data camp where you can learn the
invaluable skill of data science online
at your own pace from the same exact
courses 80
of fortune 1000 companies learn from if
i didn't get into web development before
youtube
data science would have been my first
choice because of how recession proof it
is
and data camp lets you get into this
very lucrative field even if you know
nothing about data science or coding
you can start with their data science
for business course then their
introduction to python course and then
move on to courses that combine coding
and data science
like intro to deep learning in python
and intro to python for finance
their 300 plus interactive courses are
taught by pros in the industry
and the best part university students
spend thousands of dollars and years of
their lives to learn outdated versions
of the stuff
but with data camp you get the most
up-to-date education from people
actually doing this for just 25 a month
and to sweeten the deal you can sign up
for your free account with the link
below and check out the first chapter of
any course for free at no risk to you
invest in your future today and join
over 7 million learners with the link
below
now back to bill gates o'keefe's team
followed the paper trail up the chain
that loc is associated with the angelina
agriculture company like we talked about
earlier
and one step above that angelina
agriculture is controlled by cascade
investment llc
cascade investment llc is what's called
a family office
located in kirkland washington a family
office is just a fancy name for a wealth
manager that helps out an ultra high net
worth person manage all their family's
finances
which includes their investments ultra
high net worth individuals are people
with a net worth of at least 30 million
dollars and by the end of 2019
there were a little over 500 000 ultra
high net worth individuals around the
world
and what ultra high net worth family
does cascade investment loc manage
bill and melinda gates cascade
investment also goes by the name bill
and melinda gates investments or bmgi at
the top of cascade investment is bill
gates
but bill doesn't actually touch his
money and choose his individual
investments on a day-to-day basis for
the most part
now that honor goes to the man below
gates who manages all his money
michael larson
michael larson is the chief investment
officer for the gates foundation
he does this through a lot of different
business entities with the main one
being cascade investment
now obfuscating who really controls what
through a bunch of shell companies may
sound shady
but it's actually a pretty common and
legal practice business people use to
protect their privacy
larson is also a pretty secretive guy
with one rare public interview back in
1999 with fortune magazine
where he explained how he chose the name
cascade investment because it's real
generic sounding in the pacific
northwest
larson was headhunted to work for bill
gates in 1994
and after the oa financial crisis the
farmland empire began
larson swooped up at least a hundred
thousand acres of farmland all over the
country
in places like california illinois iowa
louisiana and more on behalf of gates
this single series of acquisitions
increased gates farmland empire to seven
times the size of manhattan
by 2017 the agriculture company of
america sold half a billion dollars
worth of farmland
the agriculture company of america was
controlled by the canada pension plan
investment board
and the buyer the paper trail led right
back to none other than cascade
investment
combine those in the first purchase we
talked about and o'keefe came to the
startling conclusion
the monopoly man of operating systems is
now also the monopolist of u.s farmland
with an estimated 242 000 acres
the only question that remains is why
bill gates has been getting a lot of
we'll call it criticism for his
involvement in certain things that you
inject into your arm and his potential
profit motive or power motive with it
no comment how vaccines are a miracle
they've saved millions of lives so after
this headline came out
people understandably got a little
skeptical and concerned about bill
spreading his monopoly
that if he controls the food supply he
could theoretically create food
shortages he could theoretically control
what people eat
he could maybe do things like force the
industry to move to artificial meat
because that's what he deems best
and headlines like this and comments
like these definitely don't help
can go into those places offer the women
better tools where they want to space
birthing or have a smaller family size
and improve health because it's
amazingly as
as children survive parents feel like
they'll have enough
kids to support them in their old age
and so they choose
to have less children by doing those
well you
also set the the population growth rate
coming down
quite a bit which is definitely not
outside the realm of possibility
but that's probably not the truth
after bill bought nearly 25 000 acres of
land west of phoenix arizona
the media was quick to pick up the rumor
that bill gates was planning on building
the city of the future
a city that would be filled with the
latest autonomous tech ai internet of
things and would be a hotbed for
innovation
but in reality it turned out to be just
another average metropolis with suburban
homes and commercial real estate
because of the simple reason that bill's
money manager probably thought that it
would just be a good investment
being that the city is around buckeye is
one of the fastest growing cities in
america right now
so it's understandable that when news
broke out of bill's farmland gains
the media was quick to call bill the
sustainable agriculture champion
and how his new stake in farmland may be
connected to his fight against climate
change and his interest in our culture
in developing countries
but like most things reality is often
times a lot less glamorous than the
theories
[Music]
gates and his money manager larson have
a very simple relationship larson grows
the money
and gates gives it away in a 1999
interview
bill discusses that he talks with larson
about his investments on a weekly basis
but at the end of the day larson has
full control over where to put bill's
money
with the overall goal of investing his
billions pretty conservatively
nothing too risky and if that is still
true today
that's probably what all this farmland
amounts to a good way to grow bill's
money
when you think of investing investing in
farmland typically isn't the first thing
that comes to mind
but if you think about it farmland is a
really logical choice
everyone needs to eat the population is
only getting bigger
and until there's a major revolution in
how we grow food
there's a limited supply of land in fact
the real estate market for farmland is
actually very competitive and very hard
to get into
farm prices don't swing up and down that
much compared to things like stocks
in fact farmland returns have been
positive every single year since they
started tracking the stuff back in 1990
which is something that definitely can't
be said about stocks or even gold
or in other words farmland is very
uncorrelated to other investments
when things go down people still have to
eat and being that larsen is very
conservative with how he invests builds
money
farmland makes for a great choice the
way farmland investing usually works is
someone will buy the land and rent it
out to a farmer that can't afford to buy
it on their own
that way as the investor you get two
things the appreciation on the land
and the rent you get from the farmer
also known as the yield
just like when you rent out a house or
an apartment which is why some investors
refer to farmland as gold but with the
yield
so until bill announces some big
agriculture project in the us
you're probably not going to see any
gates foundation branded farms
it will probably be more of passive
investments leasing out this farmland to
farmers
and let's be honest becoming the biggest
farmland owner in the us
is a big deal but from bill's
perspective a half a billion dollars
here a half a billion dollars there 117
million dollars here
is just a drop in the 124.3 billion
bucket that is his net worth
[Music]
were you hoping for a more controversial
answer because i'll be honest i
sure was let me know what you guys think
about bill gates's ventures
and ambitions and goals in the comments
below
try to keep it civil if you want to
support this channel financially data
camp
again before youtube i was a web
developer and if i wasn't for web
development i probably would have chose
data science because one it pays like a
lot of money like more than web
development
and number two it's very important today
and it will continue being very
important in the very distant future and
at just 25
a month you can learn a skill that can
potentially bring in a six figure salary
you can sign up for your free account
with the link below and check out the
first chapter of any of the 300 plus
courses that you want for free
at no risk to you with the link below
you can check out the original article
that this video was based on by eric
o'keefe at the land report with the link
below
if you are new to this channel we make
video essays just like this one every
single week for free on the most
provocative stuff in the world of
business so you might also subscribe
because you have nothing to lose and you
can always dislike and unsubscribe
whenever you want
if you want behind the scenes stuff then
the live kind of stuff lots and lots of
business memes you can follow me on
instagram jaketrend.io we have a ton of
fun over there
at jtrain.io that is going to wrap it up
for this video thank you so much for
watching you've been awesome i've been
jake stay dangerous out there and i will
see you guys in the next one
[Music]
me